[Musique]
des châteaux gonflables et des drôles de
vélo ont pris place au sein du parc du
château de plaisir jusqu'au 25 août
petit et grands peuvent partager un
grand nombre d'activités gratuites en
famille
[Musique]
on disait que c'était hyper chouette
parce que voilà c'est rare qui est des
choses comme ça à disposition et
gratuite et puis les petits que ce soit
2 ans ou 5 ans ils s'amusent donc c'est
super chaque année notamment il y a les
jeux gonflables on a les cartes avec
comment dire pour les enfants donc ça
c'est des choses assez particulier
puisque ça a été que l'été on a aussi
comment dire pas mal d'activités
manuelles aussi tout au long de l'année
et là les vélos aussi en accès libre
donc ça c'est très intéressant pour les
enfants c'est la première fois qu'on
vient je trouve ça très bien c'est
beaucoup d'activités variées pour tous
les âges donc c'est parfait et du côté
des enfants c'est aussi validé je trouve
que bah c'est bien les cartes et les
vélos il y a de la bonne musique et
surtout la façon dont ils ont organisé
ça me plaît beaucoup et surtout c'est la
technologie que j'aime bien avec environ
3000 passages durant l'été les Estivales
reviennent tous les ans forte de leur
succès on s'est rendu compte qu'il y a
quelques années que durant l'été il y
avait pas mal d'enfants qui partaient en
vacances peut-être pas pendant les deux
mois et des familles également qui ne
partaient pas en vacances donc on s'est
dit que ce serait peut-être bien d'avoir
des activités gratuites pour pouvoir
occuper les familles et les enfants
ouverts du mercredi au dimanche de 16h à
19h et même le vendredi soir jusqu'à
21h30 plusieurs moments forts vont
rythmer le mois d'août vous retrouverez
toutes les informations sur le site
Internet de la ville de plaisir
[Musique]